[Music]  Haley Baldwin and Justin Bieber are in  no rush to get married a source tells ET  the couple have talked to a lot of  people close to them and are listening  to the constant advice they've been  receiving to enjoy the ride our source  adds the couple is in a loving  relationship and are working on the  foundation now to maintain the forever  he's really funny we have a good time  together he's just really sweet he's a  good kid it's a good part and I love it  the two got engaged in June after Bieber  popped the question to his bride-to-be  while on vacation in the Bahamas a  source previously told ET that just  before the singer got down on one knee  he requested everyone in the restaurant  not to take any photos or video  [Music]